hallo leute ist wieder einmal wanne und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
ja ihr habt richtig gelesen ich werde
heute donuts probieren wenn ich die
schachtel wenn man auf krieg wurde julia
herr mich schon ein bisschen besser
kennt weiß dass ich einen dorsten videos
gucken und der hat nämlich vor kurzem
gerade dunkin donuts ausprobiert und ich
dachte mir alter weiter das möchte ich
auch mal und nicht nur er hat mich dazu
inspiriert sondern auch eine kleine
heimliche leidenschaft asta mehr videos
zukunft der atem er nicht kennt der
sollte das mal bei youtube ein gsm eine
vorwarnung es könnte für manche pervers
wirken es ist gar nicht pervers gemeint
aber ja leute flüstern in dein ohr und
das sehen viele als sehr pervers an und
das zu verstehen kann ich verstehen muss
man aber nicht so sehen und der dritte
grund warum ich gerade danke nur noch
aus probiere ich weiß noch wie wir
damals vor eine million jahren auf
klassenfahrt in berlin waren und jeder
sagt dunkin donuts aufgefahren wir haben
uns alle diese boxen geholt also alle
außer ich weiß ja dass es mittlerweile
danke nun hat sich nunmehr in berlin
gibt sondern alt auch in den ganzen
anderen städten aber trotzdem kann man
es ja mal probieren
diese box hat mich unglaubliche zehn
euro gekostet ley big spender jetzt
einfach mal ein paar donuts ausgesucht
und würde die probieren wollen mit euch
flugzeug verpasst und falls sie hunger
hat dann holt euch bitte jetzt schnell
was zu essen denn sonst wird das glaube
ich unerträglich für euch achtung zurück
ok womit fangen wir an ich würde sagen
wir fangen an mit dem ganz klassischen
place donath alter sitte geil aus ach ja
und ich werde sie am ende nicht
wegschmeißen die ich also ich weiß ja
nicht schaffen aufzuessen ich hab ja
noch freunde und soli nichts gegessen
okay
dieter gail noch nie gegessen habe
diesen durchsichtigen zuckerguss hat
kann sie mit geld sie sind ist das
normal chemie lässt grüßen chemie lässt
grüßen oh ja das ist einer mit nutella
[Musik]
okay wäre aber auch schon wieder sind
gelb grünen der mittel auf jeden fall
ist dann nur keller füllung in drehen
und mit ella obendrauf verdi gotha like
eigentlich müsste ich gerade in der
trennung sein oder so dann würde glaube
ich so viel donuts essen viel mehr spaß
machen als penny fan darf natürlich
dieser donath nicht viel ein klassischer
rosa strawberry mich donath kennt ihr
das dieser dieser ganz künstliche
erdbeergeschmack zu dieser richtig war
schmeckt er immer so scheiße das könnte
ich mir bist du schön sein so künstlich
wieder okay das gleiche in weiß mit
vanille rené lilie besser immer noch
nicht so geil aber besser wenn er nicht
dieser erdbeergeschmack dran ist wenn er
gerade versucht nochmal ein bisschen aus
diesem erbe zu essen
schlechte idee einen guten geschmack
brauchen wir wenn wir einen guten
geschmack wollen erdnussbutter denn es
gibt nichts besseres als erdnussbutter
jetzt kann ich shane dawson freuen darf
vom ersten moment denkst was lecker ist
und im zweiten moment nicht die waisen
sowie das mag etwas butter das ist ein
schokolade kokosnuss donnerten
schokoladen donau schmeckt aber wie
verbrannt warum machen wir so war es
auch verkaufen die das war dein mund ist
danach auch voll trocken als ob du diese
strenge von banane gegessen als die
stränge von der banane ja mit dem mund
ring trocken nie gut lieber was buntes
leben das rote stabiler gudonis mit
erdbeermarmelade dreht er schmeckt
tatsächlich wie ein berlin in berlin hat
berlin die berliner sondern franken also
schmecken sie wie ein pfannkuchen
berlin was ihr wollt ich finde aber wenn
man beim bäcker vision berliner gut es
ist wie wenn man sich in eine eisbahn
kugel vanilleeis wenn du die gesten
krassen sachen da ist es nicht so die
sind standard noch niemanden gesehen der
sich da ist wieder eine kugel bei mir
leistikow kennt ihr jemanden der sich
bei einer eisdiele eine kugel vanilleeis
holt aber es geht ja jetzt nämlich um 1
und 2 blau.de kevin ruiz einspritz lochs
in europa ist eine füllung lebte er
schmeckt diese füllung nach nicht und
dann ich glaub es soll heidelbeeren
seiten der blaue andere muss jetzt sehen
helfen künstlichen aromen im bund
vanessa kunz live vor der kamera
willst du mich heiraten
hier habe ich einen donut den ich auf
jeden fall auf meiner hochzeit servieren
möchte würde er hat nämlich so kleine
perlen und ich glaube der donau kreis
bilden also wenn das man nicht mehr
discokugel ist dann ich habe dann noch
eine disco gesehen er kann es noch nicht
ich kann das loch mit sehr viel gefühl
ich weiß nicht womit das gefüllt ist ich
hab mir gedacht eierlikör oder so ist
okay aber die füllung da dies so willig
und hat so braune stücke das muss es
doch echt traurig wenn du den geschmack
war etwas nicht definieren kannst ich
muss in mich hinein horchen
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht womit das
gefühl dass ich mich wieder nach vanille
karamell noch schokolade nach penis
pläne schmeckt's keine ahnung fenster
frische marke buell drin fischer meine
beiden letzten und raus bist du doch
eigentlich und eine post in krien
donau-post im cream einem austin green
is what we will find out justizminister
natürlich war das heißt es nicht bis zur
posten team geschafft da versteckt sich
die post stream
gerade wie im kindergarten als das essen
nicht aufessen konnte und es musste die
auch unsere kinder gezwungen wurde den
teller auch zu essen ich kenne posten
christine vanillecreme modus und unser
letzter donau appetit gut solide eine 3
also zeug haben jetzt ausprobiert und
ich weiß dass ich so 12345 davon nicht
gut fand ein paar davon waren okay am
besten fand ich den ohne gar nichts nur
mit zuckerguss und na klar dem hotel
aber ich weiß jetzt nicht warum dunkin
donuts zu krass geheilt wird die donath
sehen schön aus aber lecker sind sie
jetzt nicht so vielleicht sollte man
auch nicht zwölf stück probieren gleich
lang ist dann auch mit dem geschmack ich
hoffe euch das video gefallen gibt wenn
danach um wenn es so ist und was nicht
ganz genau wann das nächste video kommt
denn ich bin im urlaub eine woche lang
und sie ist wieder wird aber glaube ich
wieder einen drei tage also seid ganz
gespannt ich liebe euch ganz über mein
ganzes herz liebe liebe liebe und
vergesst nicht eure oma zu füttern und
ich sehe euch dann in einem anderen
video hoffentlich mit weniger donuts
oder captain